hello I'm Chris rakus and I am uh I am a
research affiliate with MIT I'm also the
VP modeling and simulation at Julia Hub
and what I want to talk about today is
how compiler smarts can be integrated
into numerical methods in order to be
able to improve the lives of people who
do numerical Computing so specifically
I'll be talking about nonlinear solve.
JL but this applies to a lot of other of
the DU of tools within the caml
ecosystem that I'll describe so you know
so what is nonlinear solving about well
it's about finding Roots right but you
know I'm not talking about these kinds
of roots right um this is you know it's
not Roots like vegetables and whatnot
the the roots that we're talking about
when we use a root Finder right is
solving nonlinear systems of equations
right so it's for example finding you
know what are the values of X and Y that
make a s a certain system uh you know
solve right and so here's nonlinear
solve. right you might be familiar with
r mat lab or python or what whatnot but
you know here's you know not your solve.
jail it works in Julia you define your
function that says you know I have X and
Y I have these two equations I want to
satisfy you move everything over to one
side you say okay this needs to be equal
to zero this needs to be equal to zero
you give it an initial condition and you
know you give it a you define the
problem from that and boom when you
solve it you get um your you get your
solution right you get X and Y that that
solves this so okay therefore therefore
that's all you needed right you know
this is this is what you had before this
is the Julia version of it we're done
right but um it turns out that you know
you don't need to just do simple cases
like what's shown here you know not
everything in this world is simple so
there's a lot of other cases that need
to happen so for example you know what
if I need to find where a ball bounces
onto the ground right then you're
effectively finding where does position
of t equal equal to zero right so
there's other cases that need to happen
with nonlinear solvers and there's also
it can get very complex so you know
everything to do with chemical reaction
systems macroeconomics you can always
describe what an equilibria is as the
forward rate equals reverse rate you
know find all of the variables and all
the parameters such that everything
equals zero right so it turns out that
you know not everything is not
everything is this simple world we might
need tooling that extends us and scales
us to very difficult types of root
finding problems right and so that's
really what what nonlinear solve is all
about so and and so what makes nonlinear
solve special right I think that you
know a lot of people look at this they
go okay I have a Newton method in Python
I have a Newton method in R this is the
Newton method in Julia right it's the
same thing right um and but I I want to
kind of showcase how it's a bit special
because it does anti-black boxing of
code so say for example you have this as
your representation of of a nonlinear
system you want to solve right now the
reason why someone who is you know
mathematically numerically smart might
want to say Hey you know you might want
to say Hey you know don't don't solve
the the nonlinear system like this right
so Newton's method has to do L
factorizations which has o of n Cube
scaling effectively and and I mean
there's some ways it's O of n Square
details details but effectively you know
you have o of n n Cube scaling and so we
have five equations and so you know it's
like 25 or you know five to the thir
power amount of work right and someone
who's a smart mathematician might say oh
you know but maybe I can come up with a
better way of solving this system of
equations you know so that way
I can save on the amount of work right
but here's the thing right anything that
a mathematician can do a computer can do
right um and so what we're doing with
with nonlinear solve. JL is is
effectively that so here's here's a
system of equations and we say you know
solving a system of five equations is
solving is much harder than solving a
system of one equation so let's
transform it and so you what we have is
you you can say structurally simplify my
set of equations um and you can take
five equations and'll spit out and say
okay this is the only equation that you
have and all of your other variables are
defined explicitly by these
relationships um you know here I'm
showing this through the modeling
toolkit symbolic syex but you can also
apply this directly to code right it
doesn't matter if if a function is
defined by code or symbolics it can
perform these same simplification passes
and from that then you know if you only
have one equation that needs to be
solved everything else is explicitly
derivable from from that one variable
then let's solve for that one variable
right so here what it's going to do then
is it says okay I only have the equation
in terms of u5 Now give me an initial
condition for u5 and it will build in on
your problem and solve it and here I'll
give you a solution to you know it's
giving you a solution to the system of
equations by giving you only a single
solution right what single solution what
single value did it give you well gave
you you five because that's the piece
that it simplified it all down to that
u5 is a function here of hpod of u4 and
U1 but U1 is just a function of u5 u4 is
a function of U2 u3 d da da it's all
just u5 at the end of the day so what it
does is it says I just solve for u5 and
so I give you a solution in terms of one
variable but now you can query it and
you can say okay what is the solution of
the other variables and if you ask it
for the other variables you'll be able
to generate them on Demand right and so
you know this isn't this is isn't your
your Papa's uh you know Newton method
you know this is the new kit on the
Block Newton method which is really
integrating you know this symbolic
tooling in compiler analyses be able to
bring down you know a problem that is
you know five cubed in cost down to one
cubed in cost right and so it's using a
lot of compiler smarts along the way one
now you know if for for sufficiently too
large systems it can be difficult to do
the to do this kind of simplification in
practice uh though alas illumination
tearing and such there are ways that we
are working on scaling them but other
things that we can do for example
involve uh using automatic compiler
sparcity right so you know currently in
in tools like scipi right you know they
kind of say you're like oh you're going
to come you want to solve a
numerical nonlinear system well I'm
going to use a new uh Newton method
right and you know if you get to a
system that's sufficiently large it says
Oh either use a krylo method or use a or
give me your sparsity pattern right now
the downside of using a krylo method is
that in order for kof method to converge
fast you do you should be Pro providing
a preconditioner and those are problems
specific and that's not too easy to do
right so there's user input to do that
but on the other end in order to specify
the sparsity pattern right you kind of
have to know like oh hey you know for my
system the sparsity pattern of my Matrix
is this sparse Matrix right um and in
some cases that that you can write these
down but it's not always trivial to
compute what your sparsity pattern is
right so the way that tools like scipi
and stuff will work today is they just
say I'm going to use dense you know
Newton's method unless you give me a
sparity pattern
but does that actually need to be done
right you know do we actually have to
Def you know do we have to put this work
onto users or could we as package
developers actually solve this problem
for the users right um and this is where
uh you know nonlinear solver autoc
compiler sparcity comes into play right
so we showed these algorithms back at a
program Transformations Workshop in 2019
and now we've really integrated them
into the whole system where let's say
you have a complicated nonlinear system
right it can be a you know put neural
networks inside of there to find a
partial differential equation you know a
whole a whole Jiggy Jag of of difficult
pieces right there's a general code that
goes right here and what you could do is
you could say you know build a problem
and solve the problem when you do that
it'll use an automated solver right but
you can then dig into who it a little
bit more and you can say Okay I want to
use a Newton cry method I want to you
know and those are the standard things
that you'd expect from other non solver
packages but here you can say is hey use
automatic differentiation to be able to
comp the Jacobian and do auto sparse for
diff right and what this does is it
automatically it uses you know it uses
this algorithm which you you can look up
we we we describe the algorithm uses
this algorithm to automatically discover
from your code what the sparsity pattern
should be right um You can compute this
because effectively you know that your
sparcity pattern is going to be have a
zero only if um you know for all inputs
only if there's no way that input I
could it could it could affect input J
right so you really just have to trace
through your code it's a taint analysis
to basically say you know does this
input ever taint this output um so fully
automatically we discover what the what
the sparity pattern is and then we apply
uh we apply uh uh you know optimizations
with makes use of the sparity pattern in
both the way that the Jacobian is
generated and in the way that we do the
solving of the nonlinear system so in
terms of the factorizations um and not
only that it also automatically makes
use of automatic differentiation for
that sparse Jacobian construction um and
you can use this also in a ways that
that also defines an IOU for for
automating the preconditioners for C
Newton krylo methods and so this this
takes what we say is that very difficult
part right you know what do you do about
defining your sparsity pattern what do
you do about defining preconditioners it
takes this very difficult aspect of the
numerical you know setup process away
from the user and turns it into a fully
automated piece through compiler
analysis right so you know I just want
this is this is the core of nonlinear
solve and what we wanted to solve how do
you get this to the user but then the
next question that goes along with it is
well you know if we just have a
standalone nonlinear solve kind of piece
and it just you know it just is its own
thing it's not going to be as useful as
it's as if it's integrated in with the
whole ecosystem right and now what we
were looking at is well there there is
an ecosystem of equation solvers that
does exist within Julia right there's
these differential equation solvers
there's linear solvers and so you know
in in this in the same vein you know
like how scipi has everything play
together the juliao ecosystem is
building something that it covers a bit
of a larger domain and with these kind
of of compiler enhanced tooling but in
the same way it all plays together right
and so I want to kind of paint a picture
now of how everything looks in terms of
the differential equation solver space
and then say how do we map that over to
nonlinear solvers so that way you know
all of these compiler smarts nonlinear
solving tools now feel seamlessly
integrated with the rest of the
ecosystem um and so you know this one
this has a common interface between
optimization integrals M solve you know
all all these pieces that you'd expect
within a scientific Computing Library
I'm going to show you now what some of
the stuff looks like and and some of the
results we have for differential
equations and how we map that over to
then the nonlinear systems right um so
the first thing is that we really focus
on Speed and Performance right so in in
terms of the differential equation
solver speed I think a lot of people
have uh have actually seen and tried you
know some of the Julia differential
equation solver tools and saw about the
50x faster than scipi 50x faster than
matlb 100x faster than de Sol and R and
there's a lot of benchmarks and details
that go into exactly why that's the case
um if you're interested in in actually
being able to you know by pen and paper
predict that that performance result um
I'd say go to the Julia for biologist
paper it's a nature methods paper that
has a very distinct description of why
we have this performance difference
against scipi even when number is
involved right this number this number
is with a number right um so you know so
there's this performance advantage that
we have because of the algorithms and
there's a certain form that we've been
taking to be able to get this
performance Advantage so what we wanted
to do with with nonlinear solve is you
know not just have the compiling smarts
but we wanted to have exact exactly the
same bench benchmarks should look the
same way code optimization should look
the same way the input code should look
the same way we should get very similar
results to this because this is one of
the pieces uh that we've been for one of
the reasons why we've been seeing a lot
of adoption in in the
ecosystem um you know and this this is a
slide then pulled from a lot of the
discussions on differential equation
solvers stability stochasticity you know
ad joints uh inference and parallelism
right everything should work on gpus
everything should be able to be
differentiable um everything should you
know have be very robust right all of
the same things that we have for
differential equations we want to make
sure that all of those exist within
nonlinear solve as well um so here
here's a slide that shows the GPU
performance right um so the dyq GPU the
the GPU solvers um there's there's a
paper that we have I forgot to link the
paper name here um but if you search for
it you you'll find that um you know the
approach that we take to doing GPU
programming is very different from a
machine learning library and that we
directly generate the the kernels right
so we generate PTX kernels instead of
using array kernels and that ends up
being a whole lot faster than the
machine learning type of approach so
here we are benchmarking against Jax
with uh with its vmap approach and we
show that it's about 20x to 100x faster
that we're about a 20x to 100x faster
over a range of problems with Cuda and
we support Cuda we support Intel gpus we
support AMD gpus and also Apple gpus it
also supports um the graph core IP as
well right so this is the kind of thing
where you know the differential equation
has this feature so anyone kind of
coming to coming from the differential
equation space the nonlinear sofware
space would expect similar uh
performance gains and similar um GPU
compatibility so we wanted to make sure
that we kept all these features and also
a static compilation to web assembly
right the ability to take a code that
that has a solver embedded into it and
generate uh web apps that are fully
JavaScript um that that can do this so
you know so that that's that's what we
have in in the differential equation
solver space so how do we Bridge the
expected features and the expected form
of differential equations and linear
solve how do we how did we map this over
to nonlinear solve. JL so that way it
would have the same experience to a user
as um as the differential equation
solvers so you know it ends up then
being a new part of this set right I put
I put it in here in the middle but it
actually can kind of the differential
equation solvers came first then linear
solve then optimization and so nonlinear
solve is actually like the new kit on
the Block that had to kind of map into
this existing
ecosystem and you know what what what we
have is what we have is is a formul
format that is this kind of you define a
function you define your bounds or or
your initial conditions you define a
problem you define solve right it turns
out that every single one of the
equation solvers in this form whether
it's integrals optimization all the
different differential equation types
all of them have exactly the same form
that you define the function that you're
going to be interacting with you Define
the initial conditions or par and
parameters you define a problem type
right um and then on that problem type
you hit solve right um and then you know
same thing so but when nonlinear solve
you know instead of having you know
instead of having like differences
between Odes and SDS in this case we
have different forms of root finding
equations right so one form of an root
finding equation is the interval
equation interval refining problem so he
Express this as a interval nonlinear
problem right so we have different
problem types for the different cases
that can show up and the interval one
says okay between U being 1.0 and 2.0 um
the solution uh to F of f of upu should
be equal to zero within here right um
and now for nonlinear problem well this
is your standard nonlinear problem which
we consider to be the systems of
equations right now there's there's
other interactions in that we that we
made sure to have so that way it' feel
seamless with the rest of what we have
in the scientific machine learning
ecosystem um so for example if you have
an OD right so here's your OD syntax
again you you define what f is in your
OD you define the right hand side you
give an initial condition in a time span
and you have a problem type right so you
have an OD problem type in the OD case
you have a nonlinear problem in the
nonlinear problem case right you know it
has the syntax all looks exactly the
same but if you want to convert between
the two right a very common thing to do
in modeling is to say well I want to
know where an OD um has has has a has a
steady state a steady state is defined
as where all the derivatives are equal
to zero it's solved as a nonlinear
problem right so what you can do is you
can take an OD and put non steady state
problem on top of that and now it
generates you know this nonlinear
problem for the for the steady state uh
solving equation and now right here this
is an interpret Ed as something in the
nonlinear solve space and then you can
solve it using any of the options or Sol
solvers or methods of nonlinear solve.
JL right and so where there you know
this happens a lot in mathematics that
there's a lot of connections between
different ways of representing problems
right where you know not not uh you know
implicit solvers of differential
equations are solving nonlinear systems
and all sorts of connections and so what
we've done within the ecosystem has made
it so that way you can do these
conversions of problem types uh to be
able to much more easily mix and match
the different numerical tools you want
to employ um and another thing that that
we made sure to do to make it feel fully
integrated with the ecosystem is uh make
it so that way all the options for how
to you do the linear solving um is using
this this other library right again we
have these different sets of libraries
and linear solve is what we've been
using as a linear solvers within
differential equations. jail all the
same choices then exist within the the
nonlinear solvers in fact this option is
exactly the same between the OD solvers
the SD solvers the differential
algebraic equation solvers and now the
nonlinear system solvers for nonlinear
solve um and this means that everything
that we've done with linear solve which
is a different video you can go check
the Julia con right everything that
we've done to you know make sure that we
can interface with pariso kou umfpack
all the different ways of handling
sparse linear solves um those carry over
into nonlinear solve. jail which is
something that you don't see in higher
level languages very much right you know
higher level languages like in scipi you
can choose to do it you know it's it's
dense versus sparse but you don't really
have a choice between the Myriad of
different sparse uh solver you know the
sparse Lu factorization methods out
there which have different
characteristics on different uh sparsity
patterns and so this kind of keeps a lot
of flexibility in how you can choose the
solver back end to be optimized to
different types of Spar City patterns um
now one of the things that we cared
about a lot when when building this was
it should be fast and the way that we
did this is that we we made sure to to
use a lot of the same principles as what
we use within the other parts of the
ecosystem but one of the other
interesting things that we found was
that we actually ended up pretty robust
by the end too so um one of the things
that we weren't really expecting was
that minac which is actually the the for
Tran Library that's underpinning what
CPI uses um so we we found a set of of
hard Benchmark problems there's a
there's a group that's published these
hard Benchmark problems um and it turns
out that minack only solves 21 out of 23
of these problems and we're able to work
uh on some new methods for trust region
um new new new trust region heris and
also new line search heris that was able
to be a bit more robust and solve all of
them on the on the first pass um you can
you can check this out at siml
benchmarks if you search for it we keep
a auto uh basically as part of our our
continuous integration process we keep a
benchmarking server going that is then
generating all these benchmarks as we go
along and and we're now looking for some
more difficult benchmarks to add to the
system because we got a a full win on on
some of our methods right so we're we're
currently adding new new harder problems
in to be able to get some more losses um
but you know our current state is that
we tend to have some pretty robust
solvers and um you know how fast does it
end up being well I think to to really
understand the the performance
difference here um you can one way to
understand it is to look at this this
tweet that that we that came out of ma
math works right they they described how
you know for this nonlinear Pro for this
uh nonlinear solve problem uh it's an
interval root finding problem this time
um they said okay we went from you know
5.8 seconds to 1.66 seconds on on a
recent mat lab and they're proud of this
this Benchmark so what we said was well
what happens if we do solve the same
problem right um you know so solving the
same problem with roots. JL and Julia
ends up being about 0.46 seconds right
which is already three times faster than
the 1.66 but this is root .j not our new
you know smarter nonlinear solver and
when we try our new one we get down to
0.06 seconds and actually my student uh
was telling me earlier today that this
is actually down to
0.005 seconds um there's a there's an
optimization that we have in inside of
here of details details so that should
be in the next version I think coming
out about next week that we'll actually
get another 3x on this case but you know
this shows you that the the progression
then of the timings um by using
different aspects of you know compiler
optimizations um you know nonlinear
solve then is is really flexible so when
when we're doing these benchmarks right
you know how do we keep a CI system that
is benchmarking you know the for tring
codes and and all of our new solvers and
everything we we don't treat them as
separate what what we've done is we made
it so that way we we also wrap all the
all these same fortrend codes and the C
codes and we directly have the ways to
be able to call them um and the reason
one reason for that is we just want to
have every method Under the Sun uh so
this this this right here is really
trying to show that there's just tons
and tons of different solvers I can't
even show all of them in one screenshot
there's about I think like 40 nonlinear
solvers which includes WAP methods from
Fortran and WAP methods from C but then
also new methods in Julia and you know
some of them are specialized to small
equations others are specialized to
large equations uh wrapping the other
solvers in Julia as well so everything
possible we're putting in one interface
so we could just continually Benchmark
across all of them another part big part
of the flexibility too is alternative
termination modes so being able to be
very clear about here I only want to I
only want to stop the the the in uh the
nonlinear solve when I hit a certain
condition and there's a whole different
set of conditions um these are resolved
in a compile time so it optimizes a lot
of different pieces about how the
termination modes are used so that way
can cut out some computations um so one
of the nice things that we've really
done with the the differential equation
solvers is we made it have automatic
solver detection right A lot of these
libraries for OD solving they say oh you
know tell me what you want to use a
fifth order rung auta method or Ral
method or whatnot and we said no if we
if we can actually inspect your your
function f then we can actually probably
figure out what a good uh method is for
you and we've carried this over idea
over now to nonlinear solve. JL so the
syntax is almost exactly the same as the
OD case you know you just Define your
problem you call solve and what it does
is it uses these kind of poly algorithms
now which you know so for example these
poly algorithms what they'll do is I
mean it's very easy in a nonlinear
system to know whether you solve the
problem or not right so you can do
something that's like a fast method and
say oh you know bren's method is going
to be the fastest for large problems
because you don't have to calculate
jacobians or whatnot um let's try that
for a few iterations if it's not
converging fast enough let's kick out of
that and go to some kind of Newton
method and you know so there's these
kind of poly algorithms I can make use
of on by default that are choosing
different combinations of methods in a
way that's either trying to get you know
the fastest version or trying to guess
that what the fastest version is or a ro
super robust version a version that is
mixing a bunch of different robust
methods but you know these kind of poly
algorithms I think are something that
you know they don't really exist within
a lot of libraries before non yourself
but I think a lot of users of numerical
libraries you know you tend to go well
if I need this to solve I'm going to
Loop over a list of solvers right and
these poly algorithms and and the
default algorithm is effectively doing a
smarter version of loop overall
algorithms and find out which one
actually works right um so it's kind of
built in the system then how it's doing
that and how it has you know quick
endings to be able to then know which
one which one in compute graph would be
the next best choice and and things like
that um everything here just like with
the other parts of siml are all GPU
compatible so it all works together uh
with the GPU computing and we'll be
doing some tests on the Kernel
generation aspects as well soon um and
it supports Auto batching so so if you
want to solve many different on your
solve problems at the same time putting
a for Loop over it versus using this
batch form it turns out that there's
some batch optimizations you could do in
the L factorizations and such and so we
have some batching optimizations which
is similar to what we have in the OD
solver case as well um so that that's
that really means that what we've done
with nonlinear solv we really made it
integrate with anyone who's using other
parts of these libraries the
differential equation solvers or
optimization methods um Can effectively
kind of almost brainlessly just say okay
I'm just going to guess the syntax and
do the same thing and it should end up
working and you should get the similar
results in terms of okay gpus work the
same way and uh and optimizations work
the same way and and all the all these
things are built to be the same um now
with with this new you know nonlinear
solve library that has the simplif if
ification tooling and and auto sparity
tooling integrated into it right so it's
it's it's not about just having the
compiler integration but it's also
integrating uh the the ecosystems
together I think that that's an
important part now one of the last
pieces is integrating scientific machine
learning right so this is why we're siml
and not just you know you know scipi 2.0
but and and so what what exactly is the
scientific machine learning aspect so
what we do with scientific machine
learning is we integrate the way that
you do model building with machine
learning to be able to effectively do
machine learning with small data and do
things like automate the discovery of
missing equations within models um so
what does that look like so let's let's
say you had a had an equation and when
you solve your equation and you check it
against Real you check your solution
again you know you you build your model
you solve your equation you check it
against Real data you don't actually
have a fit right your your fit your your
solved model is very far away from your
data right so one of the things that
we've been kind of showing in the OD
space is that if your model far away
from the data what you can do is you can
take your physical model you can extend
it with neural networks and then use
that to be able to find out what's wrong
about your model and then you mix that
with with some symbolic tooling to be
able to spit out how you should be
changing your code you know what
equations you should be adding to your
code such that it will then improve the
the predictions from your model right so
it actually spits out code and equations
for for how to do this autoc completion
of your model and in the OD case we've
been doing this all the time right so
here for example is with Lio black hole
data if you assume you know Newtonian
mechanics and you are looking at binary
black hole system you can train on a
very small amount of data and then be
able to extrapolate and show that you've
actually learned the relativistic
corrections to Black Hole Dynamics right
and so this is something that we
actually do standard now inside of our
optimization libraries and our inside of
our OD solver libraries and we wanted to
make sure that we had the same
experience with Nar solvers and what
what does that look like well what what
that really means then is that you know
if you were to you know take a a
nonlinear system and put it inside of a
loss function so you say I Define a
nonlinear problem and I solve it and I
do something with it against data inside
of a loss function if you stick if you
do things like a forward mode automatic
differentiation or reverse mode
automatic differentiation over this over
this loss function um it will just do
all the optimizations that are required
so it'll make use of these kind of
implicit adjoints or implicit
differentiation rules is doing this
automatically behind the hood this is
this is the optimal code for this
problem um and so what that means is
then you know all the things that you'd
want to do was say back propagating you
know neural n you know this this F then
can have a neural network inside of it
and it will know how to automatically
back propagate this F that's defined by
a neural network that's inside of a loss
function of a nonlinear solve right so
all these things then compose seamlessly
and we actually demonstrated this fairly
recently in something called Deep
equilibrium networks this is a case
where you try to find the U such that a
nonlinear a neural network of U equals
zero right it's a it's a nonlinear solve
root finding problem that's defined by a
neural network and then giving having
some nice properties uh they're they're
effectively infinite layer neural
networks because they're neural networks
that are taken to the you know to the to
the point where if you're to do another
application of this neural network you
get the same result so it's a infinite
layer in a very well- defined sense um
and we and we showed that we can
actually improve a lot of other ways of
doing decks just by you know just by
using a explicit approach with an with a
with a implic with the implicit approach
you can read the paper for details but
effectively this was all done with
nonlinear solve this was all done in a
way that gives you about eight times
faster than the vanilla deck and
everything using this new nonline solve
library and all that we did was we just
you know we just took a neural network
stuck it in the right hand side use the
nonlinear solvers and now the standard
nonlinear solvers of Julia are the ones
that you would use to kind of do the
these special uh uh machine learning
layers right there's no special separate
machine learning library to learn the
standard tools of Julia all interconnect
with machine learning and with all the
other tooling that we have around there
and um yeah that's what I wanted to to
kind of show so in the end you know what
what we what we started with was we we
started with this idea of we want
solvers that are getting rid of the
blackbox and using everything about our
compiler analyses to automate the way
that we improve solvers but then we what
we did was didn't just leave it at that
as an academic exercise of is this
possible but now we we did everything
that was then required to make it be
interfacing with all the other tools in
Julia so that way it would really feel
look and feel as a new standard and um
yeah hopefully this this I we hope that
this then becomes the new standard
within Julia because we believe that
this has a lot of um advantages over
some traditional ways of building and
writing and building nonlinear root
finding libraries So yeah thank you very
much